virgin forests in Northern Argentina for
as far as the eye can see like the
Amazon rainforest in neighboring Brazil
these forests help counter greenhouse
gases they're also crucial for
minimizing landslides and floods which
is why Argentina passed Landmark
legislation to protect forests 17 years
ago this was followed by measures to
restrict the use of fires to clear field
and laws to protect wetlands and
Glaciers which mining activities can put
in
Peril but the new Libertarian president
wants to repeal or radically modify
environmental
legislation all those policies that
blame mankind for climate change are
false and all they want with those
policies is to gather funds to finance
lazy socialists who write Third Rate
papers mle says radical changes needed
to fix Argentina's chronic economic
problems but environmentalists argue
that M's real aim is to favor big
business especially those owned by his
closest political and economic
supporters such as Eduardo elstein who
accompanied the president to New York
last
month elstein runs the irsa corporation
and is one of Argentina's biggest land
owners that includes the elosa estate
here in salta an area roughly six times
the size of the city of Bueno sidtis has
already been cleared here for crops and
cattle but the native forests on the
other half of this gigantic property the
ones that you see behind me cannot be
touched by their owners because they
fall under the protection of Argentina's
Environmental Protection Law at least
for right
now if the law is modified he'll be able
to clear the remaining 150,000 hectares
he owns the same goes for M's political
Ally former president Mauricio makri he
also owns Forest land in salta that he'd
be able to clear for planting soy
specifically on the outskirts of Bueno
Sidis a real estate project is being
built on an enormous Wetland once
exclusively home to birds and
capias these giant members of the rodent
family are being quickly
displaced rolling back on Argentina's
Environmental Conservation if approved
by Congress will accelerate The
Disappearance of natural resources and
FAA that until now have been safeguarded
by
law Lucia Newman Al jazer salta
Argentina make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer